I think you're likely to find this next
story either absolutely disgusting or
hilarious depending on whether your
instinct is to laugh or cry in these
horrible situations there's this guy
named rich Lowry litt rich Lowry is
widely considered to be one of the smart
conservatives by some okay but there's a
contingent that says this is one of the
smart conservatives he's an alternative
to cartoonish right-wingers like the Fox
News people and Stephen Miller and
whatever a rich Lowery's the editor of
the National Review it's a sort of
establishment right-wing publication and
rich tweeted yesterday and this is when
I realized satire was dead for the right
like the right doesn't understand satire
rich Lowry tweeted Trump rightfully
slamming the just the flu argument at
this briefing referring to Trump
yesterday saying during his press
briefing this is not the flu this is
vicious
this was Trump's own lie rich Lowry is
praising Trump for slamming the lie that
Trump propagated just a few days ago and
certainly for several weeks and it's a
lie which is now repeated by millions of
Trumpets who are ignoring all social
distancing guidelines Trump is the one
who from the beginning was making this
seemingly innocuous comparison it's sort
of like the flu remember Trump tweeted
on March 9th so last year 37 thousand
Americans died from the flu it averaged
is 27 to 70,000 per year
nothing is shut down life in the economy
go on we've got 546 confirmed cases of
the virus with 22 deaths think about
that here is video of Trump saying this
could be called a flu just four days ago
this was not in February this was four
days ago
pandemic by this disease
this whatever they want to quote you've
got a germ you can call it a flu you can
call it a virus you can call it many
different names I'm not sure anybody
even knows what it is
here's Trump talking about it like the
flu for weeks shudders watch it man so
you have to do that you know this is I
really think doctor you want to treat
this like you treat the flu right and
you know it's gonna be it's gonna be
anyway you all know this I don't have to
play ten clips of it but it's Trump who
kept inserting into the narrative flu
flu flu and here is Trump yesterday
saying hey guys this is not the flu this
is vicious people with great actually
common sense they said what are we right
at a lot of people have said a lot of
people have thought about it write it
out don't do anything just write it out
and think of it as the flu but it's not
the food it's vicious and then in comes
rich Lowry and again says Trump
rightfully slamming the just the flu
argument at this briefing this is like
praising someone for putting out a fire
that they deliberately started this is
like punching someone in the face and
saying I didn't punch me twice you know
I that you've got to give me some credit
for not having punched you a second time
this guy is a supposed smart
conservative have fun with that one so I
think what we have to realize here is
when we point this stuff out here's the
important message okay a lot of people
when they first hear it's like the flu
or they hear Fox News say the airports
are empty this is a great time to be
flying or they hear Devon Nunez
Republican congressman from California
say this is a great time to go to
restaurants because the restaurants are
wide open you'll very easily be able to
find a seat when we when we hear all
that stuff and then it gets worse and
the guidelines change there are a lot of
people who do a sort of pick your it's
like a choose-your-own-adventure pick
whichever position you like Trump has
now said 20 30 times it's sort of like
the flu in different ways it's a flu we
don't shut down for the fluid
yesterday he says this is not the flu
this is vicious millions of Americans
are continuing to sort of rely upon the
20 or 30 times Trump said it is like the
flu in some some way shape or form to
continue not social distancing to
continue going out there congregating in
large groups I know that you know here
in Massachusetts we are now halfway
through week three of doing this people
are taking it seriously almost
everything's closed nobody's going to
school the streets are widely empty
people at grocery stores are being very
very careful there are still states at
this point that are barely doing
anything and I know that there are
people in red states who listen to the
show who write to me and say David you
know even though our state hasn't done
anything within my city we have done
stuff the mayor that's great
okay that that's fantastic but there are
millions and millions of people it's
estimated to be 25% of the total
population or more right we're talking
about 85 million people we have 340
million people in this country 25% would
be about 85 million people who are still
not doing any kind of social distancing
and this is the sort of reason why so
we've got to be much more vigilant about
it we were fighting
you know Trump wants to consider himself
a wartime president when it comes to
fighting the virus I don't know whether
that's that's the right language to be
using but a real battle that is being
fought is the battle against
disinformation which is just spreading
virally from the right and we're gonna
continue following it and fighting it as
best we can if you ever feel like you
just don't have enough time to read all
the books you want to read you have to
check out one of my favorite apps called
blinka splink a-- stakes thousands of
popular non-fiction books and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book just
imagine how you'll be able to expand
your horizons and knowledge by being
able to soak up all of the important
insights from 10 different books in an
afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book
you've already read or use it to preview
a book before you buy the full version
and read it I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription when you go
to blink is comm slash Pakman I've put
the link right underneath this video